[Applause]
hello america
so by now you heard that aoc among
others were arrested last night
she truly is an american hero it was
brutal taken out in cuffs
well technically her shirt had cuffs
maybe french cuffs
as she did surrender without fighting
but if her pants had cuffs she would
have pretended to be in leg irons too
but real handcuffs not so much but that
didn't stop her for pretending and i
hate it when people do this to me
when i ask people to put on handcuffs
and they say i'll just pretend i have
them on
i'd be like sure and i'll pretend to pay
you after
[Laughter]
i think i think dana just
had
arrhythmia
all right
yes i pay people to wear handcuffs
but she did this because she knew the
media would obey let's watch the tape
[Music]
[Applause]
you know she'd be a great mime
like the latina version of marcel
marceau
in fact here she is later in her jail
cell
[Laughter]
of course aoc was mocked on social media
for imitating being handcuffed which is
a change from her usually being mocked
for imitating a congresswoman
that was
that's not even close to being as
disgusting as i can be she in fact was
gingerly escorted away to a holding area
where she kept up the phony display
before finally raising her fist to
supporters she then crossed her wrists
behind her back again in the faux
handcuffed position it's as tall a tail
as aoc nearly being killed on january 6.
this is a person who never met a
situation she couldn't make about her
she really is the amber herd of dc
politics
i'm surprised she didn't claim she was
nearly killed on 9 11 or during the tet
offensive or the battle of bunker hill
or that she dodged a bullet when lincoln
asked her to shut up at ford's theater
but you know what i get it nothing makes
you cooler than getting arrested for
taking a stand you know i should do that
hi there does your weak reputation need
a boost from a criminal situation
introducing fake arrest reputation
transformations we'll overhaul your
image by arresting you for cool crimes
in front of your friends and family and
unlike my ex-wife's diet pills we
actually get results just listen to our
satisfied customer dwayne
as you see our quarterly numbers of two
percent exceed our forecast of 1.944
hold it right there you're under arrest
for illegal drag racing running an
underground fight club and exceeding the
maximum donation to the salvation army
let's go
screw you pig
dwayne was such a badass i want him to
get me pregnant
me too
i don't think that's a real number
but you know i do not blame aoc at all
she knows she can play the media because
they so desperately need her to play the
public it's like bob seeger saying in
that classic song night moves i used her
she used me but neither one cared we
were getting our share
it's like that picture of the border
agent that went crazy viral agent whips
migrants the media screamed in unison
like the tabernacle choir stubbing all
their toes at the exact same time
biden said he'd get to the bottom of it
like it was his afternoon bowl of cream
of wheat
then when adults informed the press that
no those were horses reigns you effing
jackasses the story went away
without one correction
instead in a move that would make kafka
say this situation is my name-esque
no
thank you
jim said it was a good joke
[Laughter]
great joke they punished the agents even
after they were found innocent
yeah and trump was supposed to be the
dictator but the story isn't about them
or the squad it's about the media of
course you choose to emit facts to
create and then preserve their narrative
what you're seeing is kabuki news where
participants play act and the media
pretends it's real then amplifies it to
the public it's constant and it only
flows in one direction but today
thankfully with help a savvy consumer
can see right through it and who can you
thank for that
[Music]
expected more applause but okay
most americans now know that what the
media presents isn't real but artificial
representations of a bigger hidden story
it's like that little trash can on your
laptop screen it's not really a trash
can
and you aren't really dragging that
incriminating photo and throwing it away
even when it makes that really cute
sound
but it wants you to think it is it's all
just symbols representing actions going
on behind the user interface that we
never actually ever see
what you do see however is what they
allow you to see there's lots of other
stuff going on behind the scenes i mean
who knows how many cryptic texts emails
and bodily fluids are exchanged between
journalists and polls for such favorable
coverage but that's the news or how the
news presents the news
example again this photo a border patrol
agent on horseback a black migrant a
whip that's all you need the media
thinks so they blew it up but behind
those images is a truth they won't tell
you because it's too much work and it
betrays their aims so what was the story
behind the story the border patrol agent
is doing his job that the government
won't do protect the border the whip is
a rain used to control the horse on
rough terrain the black migrant is an
illegal alien and agents are actually
looking out for his health too
that's the story behind the images same
thing with the squads protests it's also
clear so why bother telling you the
truth the tv picture is worth a thousand
words and is a thousand times more
powerful when not explained in its
proper context whether it's the new york
times or cnn they use images falsely to
represent the reality that often isn't
the reality at all same thing with war
pictures of legit suffering and rubble
i'm sorry i'm confusing those with what
i see in cat's office
but better not question what's going on
behind that image
like how did we get here was it
preventable can it be stopped no shut up
and enjoy the slideshow we put together
for you you adults but people are
catching on the confidence in the media
is almost down to zero we call it the
jesse waters effect
he can't hear you
but that's a good thing because it will
hopefully lead to new things you know
fox news came about from a
dissatisfaction over a monolithic
leftist media and remember necessity is
the mother of invention well unless it
identifies as a dad hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else